so we begin with breaking news Russia's
defense Ministry saying its forces have
now captured the Eastern Ukrainian town
of Soledad the Strategic town has been
the site of fierce battles in recent
days between Ukrainian troops and
mercenaries from Russia's Wagner group
solidar is just 12 kilometers from the
regional capital of bakmut that Russia
has been trying to take now for several
months we have two correspondents on the
story Natasha Butler is in cave but
first let's talk to Ali Hashem who's
standing by for us in Moscow so Ali what
are Russia saying about the latest
situation
well Nick after a few hours of
reluctancy the Russian defense Ministry
announced a few minutes ago that it is
now in full control of solidar and that
this will give Russia the chance to
ensiege Bahamut completely now yesterday
there were announcements from the Wagner
group The Mercenary group that they are
in full control of Soledad they even
issued some published some videos for
their Fighters walking in the in this
city however Russian
kremlin's spokesperson peskov was also
reluctant to go ahead with the
announcement and he said despite the
achievements there however it's it's
early to to have such an announcement
today and just few minutes ago as we
said the defense Ministry announced that
they are in full control of of uh
solidar and and that in this uh in this
battle the use of artillery Air Force
and ground forces were all together a
big element in this uh what they
described as an achievement so this is
the picture from from Moscow for now
this is going to give the Russian forces
maybe a chance to envelop the uh the
city of bahmoud the Strategic city of
bakmud that they've been fighting for
the past few months to uh to get to it
and this is this is also maybe at
herat's the beginning of a new year
because the Russians were during the
past few weeks on hold with respect to
the uh military operations also there
were many setbacks during the past week
so it's very possible that the Russians
are going to invest a lot in this in
this announcement all right I will leave
that for a moment thanks very much
there in Moscow let's get the
perspective now in Ukraine from Kiev
here's Natasha Butler and Natasha so
what's being said by the ukrainians
about this uh what Russians say
well there's been no response yet from
the ukrainians about uh this claim by
Russia's defense Ministry that Russian
forces have now taken uh the Eastern
town of solidar no word from the
ukrainians they'll of course be looking
at this very closely treating it with
caution what the ukrainians have been uh
saying all along and until now is that
some of their forces are continuing to
resist hold on to positions we heard uh
earlier from one uh Ukrainian units on
the ground saying that it was carrying
out a number of counter-attacks in
solidar we know that the Russians have
been cautious until now to say that
they'd captured the city they certainly
said that they had the upper hand there
uh the Wagner Russian mercenary group
however had posted this video online we
heard that that from Ali Hashem there in
Moscow showing what it said was some of
its uh fighters in the center of the
city so not a totally clear picture for
now we'll have to wait to see what Keith
says what we do know though is that
there are still civilians in solidar
still stuck in solidar at least 500
including we're told 15 children you can
only imagine what a bleak and
frightening and dangerous situation it
is for them we know that Ukrainian
troops have been trying to evacuate them
but until now it's been simply too risky
to do so
all right Natasha thanks for that attend
Natasha Butler there and Keith